GEORGIA.
THOSE ARE YOUR HEADLINES.
AINSLEY: THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, JILLIAN.
TEXAS GEARING UP FOR WHAT COULD
BE LARGEST SURGE AT THE BORDER
AS 60,000 MIGRANTS ARE EXPECTED
TO REACH THE STATE WITHIN JUST
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
ONE FORMER BORDER OFFICIAL
SOUNDING THE ALARM ON WHERE
THEY'RE COMING FROM AND WHAT'S
DRIVING THEM TO THE U.S.
>> THE RESULT OF THAT IS THE
MESSAGE GOES OUT AND INSTEAD OF
HAVING A COUPLE HUNDRED
ENCOUNTERS A DAY, WE QUICKLY
WENT UP TO ABOUT 6,000.
A LITTLE BIT OF MISLEADING
MESSAGING IN THE PUBLIC TODAY,
TOO IS THEY THINK THIS IS JUST
MEXICO OR SOUTH AMERICA.
BORDER PATROL CAUGHT OVER --
CAUGHT PEOPLE FROM 150 DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES COMING THROUGH MEXICO
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THE REAL THING THAT'S CHANGED IS
THE FOCUS ON BORDER SECURITY IN
GENERAL AND ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
BORDER SECURITY IS CRITICAL TO
HOMELAND SECURITY.
THE MESSAGING HAS CHANGED.
AINSLEY: THOMASY FEELY DIRECTOR
FOR FROM BUFFALO NEW YORK HE
JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING, THOMAS, THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY, THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME.
AINSLEY: WHAT ARE YOUR BIGGEST
CONCERNS?
YOU HAVE SO MUCH EXPERIENCE WITH
THIS.
WHAT ARE YOUR CONCERNS?
>> JUST LIKE THE PREVIOUS GUEST
JUST STATED A LOT OF PEOPLE
THINK IT'S JUST MEXICANS OR
PEOPLE FROM CENTRAL AND SOUTH
AMERICA THAT ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
A TON OF TERRORISTS PEOPLE,
PEOPLE WHO ARE NATIONAL SECURITY
INTEREST ARE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER AND WE JUST DON'T KNOW
WHO THEY'RE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
GOING OR WHAT THEY ARE UP TO.
I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW I
TALKED TO SOME PEOPLE YESTERDAY
AND THIS MORNING, MORALE IS AT
AN ALL-TIME LOW AND IT'S JUST
PEOPLE REALLY NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BORDER.
AINSLEY: YEAH.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE
COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED.
WHAT ARE YOUR FRIENDS DOWN THERE
ON THE BORDER SAYING
SPECIFICALLY?
>> THEY ARE OVERWHELMED.
LIKE I SAID, MORALE IS IN THE
DIRT.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE TRYING TO DO
THE BEST JOB THEY CAN.
UNFORTUNATELY A LOVE OF COUNTRY
ONLY GOES SO FAR THEY KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T HAVE
THEIR BACK.
WHY DO D. WE CHANGE WHAT WE WERE
DOING PRIOR TON GENTLEMAN.
OUR SECURITY, AINSLEY SHOULDN'T
BE A POLITICAL ISSUE AND THIS IS
REALLY PUTTING ALL AMERICANS AT
RISK.
AINSLEY: WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT MAYORKAS SAID?
HE SAYS HE IS PROUD OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING DOWN ON THE BORDER,
WHAT HE IS DOING DOWN THERE AND
EVEN IF HE COULD THROW ALL OF
THEM OUT HE WOULDN'T?
IT'S BIZARRE HERE YOU HAVE THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
WATCHING OUR BORDER OVERRUN HE
IS OKAY WITH IT AND PROUD OF IT.
LIKE HE SAID, THOSE ARE HIS
WORDS.
YOU CAN'T TAKE THEM BACK.
WE SEE ON TV OF THE ILLEGAL
ALIENS CROSSING THE BORDER.
WHAT YOU ARE NOT SEEING IS THE
AMOUNT OF DRUGS LIKE FENTANYL
THAT ARE KILLING OUR KIDS AND
OUR BROTHERS AND OUR SISTERS AND
IT'S ROLLING ACROSS THE BORDER.
AND IT'S SAD THAT NOBODY WANTS
TO DO ANYTHING IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
AINSLEY: HOW IS THIS ALL GOING
TO PLAY OUT IN THE NEXT
ELECTION?
IF YOU TALK TO SOME CRITICS OF
JOE BIDEN THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
ARE BEING TAXED TO DEATH, THEY
ARE BEING TOLD WHAT THEIR KIDS
ARE RETURNING IN SCHOOL.
THEY ARE BEING TOLD THEY HAVE TO
GET VACCINATED AND THEY HAVE TO
WEAR MASKS IN SCHOOLS YET THESE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO JOE BIDEN
WANTS TO PUT THROUGH COLLEGE FOR
FREE ON YOUR TAX DOLLAR DIME
THEY FEEL COMPLETELY ABANDONED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
HOW IS THIS GOING TO PLAY OUT IN
THE ELECTION?
>> HOPEFULLY PLAYS OUT IN SOME
WAY, RIGHT?
THIS REALLY NEEDS TO STOP BEING
A DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN ISSUE
AND BE AN AMERICAN ISSUE.
YOU ARE PUTTING OUR LIVES AT
RISK.
YOU ARE PUTTING OUR CHILDREN'S
LIVES AT RISK.
AND WE ALL KNOW WHEN OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS GET KILLED BY AN ILLEGAL
ALIEN NOBODY CARES UNTIL IT'S
THE RIGHT FAMILY THIS HAS GOT TO
STOP BEING A PARTISAN ISSUE.
IT'S GOT TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
THE DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS,
SOMEBODY PLEASE STAND UP FOR OUR
COUNTRY, SECURE THE BORDER, SO
WE CAN TAKE CARE OF LETTING THE
PEOPLE THAT NEED OUR HELP INTO
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE AINSLEY
RIGHT NOW, THE FACT IS SO MANY
ILLEGAL ALIENS HAVE ENTERED OF
THE COUNTRY SINCE JANUARY.
ICE ERO WHO IS IN CHARGE OF
FINDING THESE PEOPLE MAKING SURE
THEY GO TO COURT WILL NEVER
CATCH UP.
AINSLEY: WHAT ABOUT AFGHANISTAN?
IT'S TAKEN OVER BY THE TALIBAN.
SHOULD WOULD HE BE WORRIED ABOUT
TALIBAN TRYING TO GET THROUGH
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
BASES IN NEW JERSEY IS WHERE WE
ARE SENDING THE AFGHANS TO BE
VETTED.
AND, YOU KNOW, THEY CAME ACROSS
TERRORIST INDIVIDUALS THERE THAT
WERE, YOU KNOW, OF GREAT CONCERN
TO WHY THEY GOT HERE AND HOW
THEY GOT HERE.
I THINK THE NUMBERS WERE OUT OF
ALL THE AFGHANS THAT CAME INTO
NEW JERSEY, ONLY 3% OF ALL OF
THEM WERE ACTUALLY TRANSLATORS
AND HELPING OUR GOVERNMENT.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE ARE JUST
EXPORTING HORRIBLE PEOPLE INTO
OUR COUNTRY AND TURNING A BLIND
EYE.
AINSLEY: THAT IS SCARY
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE READ REPORTS
IT'S BEING REPORTED THAT SOME OF
THESE REFUGEES ARE BEING ABLE TO
LEAVE THESE BASES OR THESE POSTS
AND TAKE UBERS AND GO OUT INTO
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
OF.
>> RIGHT.
AND YOU KNOW, MOST AMERICANS
THAT I TALK TO, BECAUSE I'M ONE
OF THEM.
WE GET IT PEOPLE WANT TO COME TO
THE COUNTRY.
WE WANT THEM TO DO THE RATE WAY.
WE HAVE THE STATUE OF LIBERTY.
WE WILL WELCOME YOU WITH OPEN
ARMS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A WAY TO STOP
PEOPLE WHO DON'T BLOCK HERE AND
ONLY COMING HERE TO DO US HARM.
WE GOT TO GET THEY WILL OUT OF
THE COUNTRY.
AINSLEY: THOMAS, T